some positive news on the vaccine roll
out now mixing doses of the oxford
astrazeneca and
pfizer vaccines generates a robust
immune response against coronavirus
this is according to new research the
findings could allow flexibility in the
uk and global vaccine rollouts
allowing people to receive whatever jab
is available now science correspondent
tom moore
thomas more joins me now um thomas good
to see you this is an interesting
development isn't it
yeah it's a really interesting study
action it was done by the team that
designed the astrazeneca vaccine
from oxford university and they looked
at two doses of either
the astrazeneca vaccine or the fisa
vaccine as we're all getting at the
moment
and they compare that against a mix and
match approach so you get one
or other in that as the first and the
second dose and they found that the
combination
actually produced much higher antibody
levels
than two doses of the astrazeneca
vaccine
alone uh and the two doses of fires are
still led the pack but when you look at
the t
cells this other arm of the immune
system again
it was the mix and match approach that
proved best of all
and that's hugely significant perhaps
it's a little bit too late
for us here in the uk because most
adults already had two doses and
certainly the chief medical
deputy chief medical officer jonathan
van tam
has said that uh there won't be change
in the immediate the uh
roll out of the vaccine schedule here in
the uk but it could be
applicable around the world of course
much of the world has yet to receive
even a single dose of the vaccine
but significantly here and this is the
really interesting bit the the leader of
the study said that this could
be really important when it comes to a
booster dose in the autumn
that if you've had two doses of
astrazeneca then you might
get be you might be better off with one
of the rna vaccines pfizer or moderna
because that might lead to a much
stronger response and
uh the deputy chief medical officer said
that this study
could feed in to this decision over
which vaccines you get as your third
dose if it's needed